around the country all over the world on
the screen
is that to talk about how we strengthen
our domestic semiconductor industry
and secure america's supply chain this
initiative that has
broad support in the united states
congress we talked about whether or not
we're doing anything in terms of
bipartisanly
well we are both sides of the aisle are
strongly supportive what we're proposing
and i
and where i think we can really get
things done for the american people
in fact today i received a letter from
23
senators bipartisan and 42 house members
republican and democrats
supporting the chips for america program
now let me quote from the letter it says
chinese communist parties aggressively
plans to reorient and dominate the
semiconductor supply chain
and it goes into how much money they're
pouring into being able to be able to do
that
but i've been saying for some time now
china and the rest of the world is not
waiting and there's no reason why
americans should wait we're investing
aggressively in areas like
semiconductors and batteries that's what
they're doing and others
so must we we are seeking a significant
investment
in the in this left piece of legislation
and it's important
but we know it's not sufficient the
american jobs plan that i've put forward
is part of
about revitalizing american
manufacturing
and securing our supply chains investing
in research and development
as we used to in a very healthy manner
but it's also about much more than that
it's about investing in infrastructure
and infrastructure
not for the 20th century but the 21st
century
it's not just roads and bridges we're
investing in
water systems so americans can have
clean water infrastructure
we're investing in high-speed rail
infrastructure
we're building charging stations support
america's electric
future electric vehicle future and
investing in that infrastructure
and building out america's supply chain
so we
never again are at the mercy of another
country or any other nation
for their critical needs that's what we
mean by investing in infrastructure
and uh we're investing in a more
resilient grid
investing i understand you discussed
that a little bit earlier today
investing as well in in asbestos free
schools for our kids
that's investing in infrastructure
building a support system to take care
of our elderly parents and our kids with
disabilities at home
so that people can go to work that's
investing in
infrastructure chips like the one i have
here
these chips these wafers are batteries
broadband it's all infrastructure this
is infrastructure
so look we need to build the
infrastructure of today
not repair the one of yesterday and the
plan i propose
is going to create millions of jobs
rebuild america
protect our supply chains and revitalize
american manufacturing
and it's going to make america research
and development a great engine again
we led the world in the middle of the
20th century
we led the world toward the end of the
century we're going to lead the world
again
we're going to lead it again in the 21st
century
where we have the best minds in the
country many of them are on the screen
right now
and they know better than anyone that
our competitors depends on
where you invest and how you invest
for too long as a nation we have been
making
the big bold investments we need to
outpace our global competitors
we've been falling behind on research
and development and manufacturing
and put a blunt we have to step up our
game
and i'm not ready to give up i'm ready
to work with all of you
with the congress both parties to pass
the american jobs plan
and to make a once in a generation
investment
in america's future again we'll provide
the innovation and spur breakthroughs
and we need we need to support
all your support on the screen and
others in order to get this work done
and we need you in turn to support the
american workers
american communities in every part of
the country this is a moment
for american strength and american unity
for government industry communities to
work together
to make sure that we're ready to meet
the global competition
that lies ahead not continuing the slide
in terms of our investment we're ranked
number 25th in the world now
that's not america so i want to thank
you all very much
and i appreciate all the time you've
given us
[Music]
what i'm going to do i'm going to see
you all again in a few minutes
i've just took taken the time to realize
a few minutes late to listen to the
press conference
i'm preparing a statement and i'll be
happy to talk to you at the next meeting
okay thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
you